Of course, a natural question is, well,
how accurate are these forecasts?
Can you act on them?
Do they really predict the future?
Well at least a first step towards
answering that question can be found
by back testing.
So that means you roll back time,
and you test your system.
So here's our historical data as usual
it's organized with time coming down.
Now in order to test
the capability of our approach,
we have to limit the data it sees
to a certain amount of time and
then make predictions into
the simulated future.
So we allow our system to only look
at data up to a certain point.
It can use data before
that all it likes.
It builds a model, and
then makes a forecast.
On the basis of that forecast,
we can then now place orders,
anticipating that that
forecast will be achieved.
So we might long some stocks or
short them as appropriate.
We can take those orders now,
put them into our trading simulator and
see how the portfolio works.
So this time right here is
the same as this time here, so
we enter our positions on that date
which was the same as that date and
then we roll it forward and
see what happens with the portfolio.
Using software that we've built in this
class, you can measure things like
Sharpe ratio, return, and
so on for that portfolio.
Now we're training over new data,
make a new forecast and
then make a new set of orders.
We enter these orders in our trading
simulator and then go forward and
see what happens.
I'm optimistic and it's always
going to go up and to the right.
Anyways, this process
can be repeated over and
over again using historical data and
we can simulate our learning algorithm
and how it would trade in this way.
And that's called backtesting.